it was 10 years ago today a terror
attack at the Boston Marathon two bombs
went off killing three people and
injuring hundreds of others
a decade later many stories have been
told
but many are still unfolding
the cost of this is something you're
still paying for yeah so uh be a
lifetime of paying for
Paul Norton Jackie Webb and their group
were among the thousands watching when
the attacks began at 2 49 pm on April 15
2013.
near the finish line of the Boston
Marathon we were waiting for our friend
to run by
and we heard the first blast go off and
obviously us as with everybody else
looked down Boylston Street and you saw
what was a mushroom cloud I turned to
start going towards the street and I
remember the barricade being there and
thinking like how am I going to help
that and that's when the second blast
went off
you were right here
yeah they were against the fence it's a
forum restaurant at the time so there
used to be a tree here it was actually
the backpack was placed right next to
the tree we kind of surrounded it but I
had a lot of bark that they removed
during the cleanups and debriefments for
you know five or six surgeries so they
knew I was close to the tree today in
place of the tree stands a memorial to
those killed
Jackie Webb's injuries took months to
recover from her many procedures were
made possible in part by donations from
the Greg Hill Foundation which helps New
England families touched by tragedy they
came to my hospital within 48 hours and
had a check and that I think was the
most impactful gesture that happened the
entire Marathon bombing that's what I
you know think of all the time Norton
lost his right leg above the knee and
was in a coma for eight days his brother
lost his leg below the knee
the past 10 years for Norton and Webb
have included recovery the establishment
of their own charitable Foundation
and the birth of their first child
made even more meaningful when the nurse
who treated Webb on Marathon day helped
to deliver Webb's daughter
Ella I see your necklace yes
do you wear that all the time I do yeah
and what has Ella
meant for you oh she's my world it's
it's really just you can't even put into
words what she means like she's so
special and brightens that day every day
and it's just it's beyond a blessing to
have her neither Webb nor Norton have
ever returned to Marathon day in person
preferring instead to watch on TV when
you watch the Marathon this year do you
will you watch it with nerves with
a sense of happiness that you're able to
give back now how do you feel about all
that yeah I guess it's going to be mixed
emotions
um we're obviously very grateful for
everything that's come after that but
yes there's always nerves around every
Marathon especially this one with it
being a big anniversary
um but you know we'll get through it the
web Northern Foundation is a promise to
be there for our community Jackie and
Paul's web Norton Foundation aims to
help those who do not have access to the
resources many victims of the Boston
bombing benefited from as of tonight the
web Northern Foundation has donated over
ten thousand dollars to six
beneficiaries in the first five months
that includes both physical
and mental recovery I think hands down
that made the biggest difference in our
recovery
um I think even just it being Paul
myself his brother and our group of
friends it was so easy to go and speak
to somebody else or they could you know
normalize a feeling for you and I do my
heartbreaks are people that do that
alone because I think that there is
strength in numbers in there that you
just can't explain to other people do
you want to have more kids
yes we are expecting baby number two I
didn't know that
and it's a girl I'll say it
congratulations thank you wow the
blessings continue yes yes that's great
what when does it do where's September
okay that's amazing yeah very excited
okay
they're doing so great
um and it was so good to spend time one
of the stories that I think hasn't been
told maybe as much as some of the other
ones our quick thanks to the Mandarin
Oriental uh for giving us a place to
talk to them right along Boylston there
um and our thanks to Jackie for being so
open about not just what happened that
day but you know the challenges that
they faced over the past decade that
play Boston's become a home for me also
as you know and I am always amazed at
that strength and that Bond I know so
many cities have it but it really is
there and there is no one that you talk
to that doesn't have that memory of that
day and for those that survived and that
were there
um it's it's just strength that I can't
describe and for them to share it's
really resilience I mean we all covered
it in some way shape or form not just
the incident but the recovery of those
great piece Jeff and the continuing
recovery exactly the need for her and
him to speak to others yes to help
others who don't have that support yeah